please join me in welcoming Salman Khan
welcome summer good
thank you so much good to be here next
bunch very exciting to be here so before
I start I like to get a sense of where
the audience is and how much they might
know about Khan Academy how many of you
all have either used it or somewhat
familiar with the site to certainly grow
very good very good
how many how many of you have used it
with your kids your kids actively use
the site and some oh this is very
exciting all right very good so so just
just to start off there there were some
of y'all that didn't raise your hands to
get to get everyone on the same page
Khan Academy is most known for this
collection of videos and I'll talk a
little bit about how all of this got
started but I literally started making
for my cousins and so I'll show a
montage of those videos and you'll see
what what they feel like and you'll also
see some of the other video directions
we're going in not all of them are made
by me anymore and we're starting to
experiment with some other styles so let
me just show you what that looks like we
could integrate over the surface and the
notation usually is a capital Sigma all
these interactions are just through the
gravity over interstellar or almost you
could call it integral acting this
animals fossils are only found in this
area of South America a nice clean band
here notice this is an aldehyde and it's
an alcohol is there 30 million plus the
twenty million dollars from the American
manufacturer they create the Committee
of Public Safety which sounds like a
very nice committee this is not about a
Chili's portrait the ancient goddess of
love this is 6 times 6 times 6 or 216
I'm told the humidity makes it feel
hotter why is this excellent question
LeBron let's just like make it play with
the pendulum and get a feel for how it
moves function as a bridge rectifier one
two three four five six seven eight if
this does not blow your mind then you
have no emotion
I can I can always tell the intelligence
of an audience based on how much they
appreciate Euler's identity so y'all
have uh y'all have passed that too fast
that so just to give a snapshot of where
we are now we've we've reached 75
million unique students since kind of
this adventure began over I think
actually the numbers are not 240 million
videos have been watched
we actually just crossed our billionth
exercise I know the slide says 900
million but our billionth exercise that
literally a couple of weeks ago we're
being used in 20,000 classrooms and and
you know what you saw now is just the
videos but what I want to do is rewind a
little bit and tell talk about how all
of this got started and then talk about
where we see Khan Academy going because
we think it's a lot more than than just
the videos that I initially started
making for family so if you were if you
rewind back to 2004 I was my background
is originally in computer science but I
had gone to business school I now found
myself I was an analyst at a hedge fund
and I had just gotten married and I had
some family visiting me from New Orleans
which is where I grew up they were
visiting me up in depth ammas ttan and
while they were there it was three of my
cousins and their parents my uncle or
not and the oldest of my cousins Nadia
who was 12 years old at the time it just
came out in conversation at some point
that she was having trouble in
mathematics and so I said well you Nadia
you know he seemed like a very bright
young woman what seems to be the problem
and she said it was unit conversion and
I said no you know like I'm completely
convinced that you can tackle unit
conversion and she thought it was just
one of these empty pep talks I could
kind of sense that she was rolling her
eyes inside of her brain and so I said I
kind of view that as a little bit of a
challenge so I said okay how about this
you go back to New Orleans I'm Sam in
Boston every day after work for me after
school for you I tutor you and and and
we try to get you past this threshold
and I think she was excited that you
know just someone was willing to take
this the time out for her and so she
agreed and so they went back to New
Orleans and long story short you know
every day we worked together it was
difficult at first she'd kind of psyched
herself out convinced
herself that she was no good at
mathematics but about a month into it
she she was able to things click then
she was able to catch up then she
actually started to get a little bit
ahead of the curve a little bit ahead of
where her class might be and at that
point I like to say I became what I what
I call a a tiger cousin and I uh I I
called up her her school and I said you
know I really think Nadi needs to retake
the placement exam go into the faster
math track and and they said who are you
I'm her cousin and but you know it's
it's a theme that that I guess you'll
see many times over the next few minutes
but I've seen many times over the last
few years starting with Nadia is that
that same girl who entering seventh
grade thought she was no good at math
and thought that she couldn't comprehend
unit conversion by her sophomore year in
high school was taking calculus at the
at the local university and something
we're gonna see over and over again is
that people who thought they were bad at
something are able to just if they're
able to fill in the gaps in their
knowledge are able to all of a sudden
race ahead but I was kind of hooked I I
worked with Nadia then I started working
with her her younger brothers then the
firm that I was working for I firmly it
was my boss and his dog we the dog was
the chief economist we we we we ended up
moving out to Northern California my
boss his wife got a job as a professor
at Stanford Law and the the first Khan
Academy most people don't realize it
because the videos have kind of kind of
have a life of their own
the first Khan Academy was actually a
little piece of software that I had
written for my cousin's to kind of give
them practice problems I noticed that
they didn't they weren't really
proficient at a lot of things that you
would expect someone and fifth or sixth
or seventh grade to know I was somewhat
suspicious of whether they were doing
the work so I put a database behind it
and you fast forward to 2006 I was at a
dinner party with a friend and and all
my friends knew I had this kind of crazy
project with my cousins and I was
showing off the software that I had
written these things that generate
exercises for them and and they all knew
that I had I had this this this project
but you know word had gotten around in
the family that that free tutoring was
going on
and so I found myself now tutoring every
day after work about 10 or 15 cousins
and family members and and whatever else
and and my friend he's like oh Sal you
know the software is really cool but how
are you dealing with you know being able
to coordinate all of these tutoring
sessions and I'm like you know it's
actually getting really really difficult
and he's the first person to tell me
well there's this YouTube thing why
don't you make some of why don't you
make videos of some of your lessons put
him up on YouTube maybe your cousin's
would find it useful and and I
immediately thought it was a horrible
idea I said no no YouTube is for cats
playing piano it's not for serious
mathematics but I I literally went home
that weekend got over the idea that it
wasn't my idea and I and I I gave it a
shot and you know I know first few
videos were kind of on algebra and
pre-algebra and whatever else and and I
made about 10 or 20 of them there was a
little 10 minute long videos and I
started telling my cousin's look if
you're confused about something you want
to review something there's these videos
are there for you and after about a few
months I asked for feedback and you know
they they somewhat backhanded Lee told
me that they preferred me on youtube
than in person and viewing viewing the
positive angle of that feedback I think
it actually made a lot of sense they
were saying look they appreciated the
time I was spending with them they
appreciated the tutorials but the first
time that you learn something it's
stressful to have someone say oh I do
understand this now or a lot of times
you might be in seventh or eighth or
ninth grade and you forgot some concept
from fourth or fifth grade and you might
be embarrassed to tell your cousin and
so you can now review it at your own
time and pace when people coordinate
time if you know they might have other
things going on in their day they might
have a lot of homework that night now
they could access the content when
they're ready when they're ready to
access it so I view that as positive
feedback and I just kept going adding
more and more and more and more content
then it became clear soon enough on
YouTube that that there were people who
are not my cousin's who were watching
and you know at first the comments were
just you know thank you this really
helped I really appreciated this and and
even that was a pretty big deal I don't
know how much time y'all have spent on
YouTube but the comments don't always be
our
always that positive and or even g-rated
and and and and then the comments got
really interesting there started to be
things that you know this is the reason
I was able to go back to college this is
the reason why I'm now a physics major
this is the reason why after leaving the
military I can go back and major in
engineering and you know I got crazy
emails one family said thank you so much
for this resource my entire family
appraised for your entire family every
evening and you have to put things in
perspective I was an analyst at a hedge
fund we didn't have a lot of people
praying for us I was
maybe our investors every every now and
then so III just kept going and going
and going
and in 2008 I set it up as a
not-for-profit even at that point I
didn't really imagine that it was you
know my I guess my for-profit career was
going well and I and I just assumed that
hey maybe I'll just do the for-profit
thing I'll set this up as a
not-for-profit maybe at some point I
could get some grants for it or maybe
get a couple of people to work on it but
I didn't really think of that as
something that might overtake my life
but then as little as a year after that
2009 it had overtaken my life at this
point
there was several hundred thousand
people who are using the site every
month I was getting hundreds of emails
every week I was sneaking away and
making videos and every kind of free
time that I had and so I I sat down with
my wife we had a little bit of savings
sometimes I'm introduced as a hedge fund
manager and I make it very clear and I
was the analyst there's a different pay
grade otherwise it would've been a much
easier decision and I would be dressed a
little bit better but the but I was an
analyst and and so we had some savings
about enough about a year's worth of
savings but we didn't know in a house or
our son had just been born but you know
my wife understood this kind of had
overtaken my life and and I said look
you know someone's gotta appreciate in
the next year we'll give ourselves a
year someone should appreciate that
there's almost an infinite social return
on investment here that I could keep on
making videos we could do the
interactive software etc etc could reach
millions and millions and millions maybe
one day billions of students and so I
kind of took that leap of faith and I
think like a lot of entrepreneurial
stories you start off very naively
optimistic you're already starting to
talk some to some foundations you just
yeah this is a no-brainer for them
they're definitely gonna fund this and
they don't and a few a few a few months
go by and you know in all honesty about
nine months went by and I started
getting pretty insecure and I you know
there was even a night where I started
literally updating my resume and
thinking that I would I would go back
into the world that I had come from and
right when I was right around that same
time I had some I had a place where
people could send in donations there was
a little PayPal link and I was getting
fifty dollar donations five dollar
donations every now and then a hundred
dollar donation would come in and that
that did help pay the bills but we were
digging into our savings to the tune of
about about five or six thousand dollars
a month and right when that was
happening all of a sudden a $10,000
donation came in and so I immediately
see who this is from her name was and or
her she was based in Palo Alto so I
immediately sent her an email I said you
know thank you so much for this very
generous donation this is the largest
donation that the Khan Academy has ever
received if we were a physical school
you would now have a building named
after you which which I've now
discovered is quite inexpensive for him
it's it gets to get to a bench in what
you most universities and she
immediately emailed me back and said
well I'm fascinated by what you're doing
let's let's let's have lunch and so we
literally I think it was like a week
later we had lunch in downtown Palo Alto
a little Indian buffet restaurant and
Ann said well you know what what what
what are you trying to do what's your
goal and I said look when I filled out
the paperwork with the IRS they have a
little line that says mission statement
and I said well I don't know a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and Ann said well that's
optimistic that's ambitious how do you
plan on doing that and I said well I
want to keep making videos but I could
imagine building the interactive
software even more the stuff that I
started making with my cousin's feedback
dashboards tools for teachers ways for
kids to communicate online we could
internationalize it so anyone on the
planet can can can possibly access it
and she said well you know this is
strangely enough it seems like you're on
track to do this how are you supporting
yourself and then as proud of a way as
possible I said I'm not and so and kind
of nodded and and we parted ways
she got on her bicycle I got into my car
and I drove home 10 minutes later I'm
driving into the driveway and I got a
text message from man and it said you
really need to be supporting yourself
I've just wired you $100,000 so so it
was a good day unbalanced and you know
frankly that was the beginning of a
whole cascade of stranger and stranger
events you fast forward two months I was
running you know I was like this virtual
teaching guy and I was curious what what
could you do with a physical environment
if it's not based on lecture anymore and
so I had this little summer camp where I
had about 25 middle school students and
I had six of them play a game of Risk
and then I had the other the remainder
of the students trade securities based
on the outcome of the game of Risk and
what one twelve-year-old actually
invented naked shorting and so I told
him I could introduce him to some people
they could he could do quite well but uh
while that was happening I got another
actually series of text messages for man
at this point I take her text messages
very seriously and they it was actually
hard to read but it read along the lines
of I'm at the Aspen ideas festival right
now at them in the main pavilion bill
gates on stage talking about Kahn
Academy last five minutes and so I
immediately boot the nearest seventh
grader off of a computer and I and I
start looking for evidence that this you
know what is an talking about and I soon
found people tweeting about it I was
find that even blog posts were starting
to come out in a few hours I was able to
find actual footage of the event and
Bill Bill Gates onstage with Walter
Isaacson talking about how he uses this
thing called the Khan Academy with his
kids he uses it himself which actually
was a little bit scary for me those
videos were for Navia not not for Bill
Gates and and then I went home that
evening kind of just confused and not
sure what to do next I mean do I call
him
do I what's the protocol here and and
and they left me in that somewhat
bizarre state for the next two weeks and
so two weeks later I'm literally in you
know the
the world headquarters of the Khan
Academy which was our walk-in closet and
I was making a video and then all of a
sudden I get I get a call from Seattle
so this is intriguing I answer the phone
hello and on the other side this is
Larry Cohen I'm Bill Gates his chief of
staff you might have heard that Bill's a
fan yeah I heard that if you have some
time in the near future we would love to
fly you up to Seattle and figure out how
we can support you and at that moment I
was looking at my calendar for the month
completely blank so I said yeah you know
I got to cut my nails on Wednesday but
other than that I think I could I could
fly up and meet Bill Gates so all of
that worked out went met with Bill Gates
they decided to support us be able to
hire up a team write it around that same
time we were also meeting with the folks
at Google I mean all of these things
just these independent events that just
came together all at once they also
decided to support us in a significant
way and about this is about two and a
half years ago not that long ago we were
up and running and we were kind of ready
to build what I had first described to
Ann and what you see here you know this
is kind of a I like to show this because
it kind of gives a framework for how we
think about how kids can interact and
learn with the system this is what we
call our knowledge map each of those
nodes are concepts in mathematics so you
saw the videos they go much broader than
mathematics right now our interactive
portion is mainly math over time we hope
that the interactive will also be in
quite possibly every every subject but
what you see here is that the higher you
go there are more basic concepts and as
students show proficiency or mastery and
the more basic concepts it then moves
them down to more advanced concepts and
it's kind of an obvious idea it's how
you would play a video game you master
level one then you go to level two it's
how you would learn a martial art it's
how you would learn a musical instrument
but the thing that I always point out is
this is not the way that you are taught
in a traditional classroom in a
traditional classroom you group kids by
age you push them through in kind of an
assembly line factory model and it's
actually no coincidence this model was
developed really during the Industrial
Revolution at different points in time
usually state-mandated you kind of try
to apply information to them some kids
get the information some kids don't
even if a kid gets a C on say basic
exponents that's and you identified
those weaknesses you move on to negative
exponents or fractions or something more
advanced even though you know that that
they had they had weaknesses in
something more basic and the analogy I
draw there is imagine if you were
building a house and you get the
contractors and you tell the contractors
look we have the state tells me we have
exactly three weeks to build this
foundation do what you can so the
contractor does what they can you get
the inspector to show up after two-three
weeks and the inspector says well yeah I
don't know the concrete's still a little
bit wet right over there this part right
over here isn't quite up to code I would
give it an eighty five percent they said
great that's a C let's build the first
floor and you build the first floor you
know two weeks of you know you tell the
contractor look you just have to spend
two weeks I don't care if the supplies
don't show up I don't care if it rains
do it you can inspect your shows up 75
percent great let's build the second
floor and you do that floor after floor
after floor and then all of a sudden
while you're building the fourth floor
and the whole thing collapses you blame
the contractor you say oh my god I had a
horrible contractor or maybe you say oh
we didn't inspect good enough but the
reality is maybe those things were fine
but you the process was broken the
inspector was identifying weaknesses but
you completely ignored them and you
moved on to the next concept and this is
essentially what's happening in our
schools every day and so what we're
saying is look instead of holding fixed
when and how long you have to learn
something and the variable is how well
you learn it pretty much ensuring that
you end up with all of these gaps that
are gonna make you hit a wall later on
in your in your career let's make the
variable how long you have to learn it
and when you learn it essentially
personalize the instruction for your
needs but the fixing is that you have a
high level a high level of mastery now
this is just an example of of what at
some of these exercises look like I
showed you know we mentioned that a
billion of these have been done and I
like to show this one this is kind of
like Montessori for calculus it kind of
shows you that you can change the slope
of the tangent line at any point and by
doing that you're essentially plotting
the derivative you know when I we
started this whole thing
I I assumed Khan Academy was just gonna
be this thing outside of classrooms that
you know the the the school system was
this bureaucratic thing with a lot of
inertia
but right when we got some of that first
funding a local school district reached
out to us Los Altos and said look what
would you do with a 5th grade classroom
now with your tools and we said look we
don't think there's a reason to use
class time for this passive one size
fits all lecture big students can get it
on demand I told them how my cousin's
like that even more and we could use
class time format more valuable things
for interacting with the teacher for a
peer-to-peer instruction the irony here
is if the kids can learn at their own
time and pace off when they're not in
the classroom the classroom could become
a more human experience because they had
this technology and and somewhat
surprising to us they said it yeah this
is this is exactly consistent with
differentiated instruction mastery-based
learning these concepts that have been
in education circles forever and we want
to do it so we started a pilot and what
you see here is some of the dashboards
from that initial pilot and it gives you
an idea of how these classrooms could
work so each row is there it's kind of
like a spreadsheet each row there is a
tee a student in the class each of those
columns is one of those concepts that
you saw in that knowledge map green
means that the students proficient blue
means that they're working on it and red
means that a student is stuck on it and
the model is a teacher can walk around
literally updates in real-time it shows
up on their tablet and they could say
okay that students having trouble with
exponents three there's a couple of
students who've already mastered that
maybe I can set up a little peer
tutoring between them or if they're
still having trouble maybe I can sit
down and do a very focused intervention
or maybe if a bunch of students have
already mastered a certain concept I
cannot do more interactive maybe a
project based on based on that type of a
concept this next chart or graph we have
a ton of dashboards for teachers so that
we could really give them the type of
analytics frankly the type of analytics
that we were seeing before in the market
analytics or the type of analytics that
I had when I was an analyst at a hedge
fund
we can finally give that to a teacher so
they can in real time slice and dice
what all of their students are up to but
I like to show this one because above it
you know above and beyond just showing a
report it talks about a very powerful
narrative essentially the same narrative
that I had first seen with Nadia the
horizontal axis there is just time it's
just days on the side the vertical axis
is just a count of how many of those
modules a student has shown proficiency
in and each of those lines is a student
in a classroom and what you see is and
just like any math
shroom right when you start there's a
group of kids very steep slope they
start advancing really fast there's a
group of kids in the middle and then
there's a group of kids who are really
slow to start those are the flatter
lines and in a traditional model you say
oh those kids who are racing ahead those
are the those are the honors students
those are the kids who are you know
gonna go to college come engineers and
doctors and all the rest we have our
kids in the middle and their kids in the
slow kids
yeah maybe those kids are the remedial
students but what we're seeing is if you
let every student learn at their own
pace if you let them fill in the gaps
that you thought that they weren't able
to fill in before the same students that
we thought were remedial ten days into
the process or mediocre ten days into
the process and this blue student is one
of them and actually clips off a little
bit on the right but on the right it
even at day seventy something you see
that there's a third third best student
but this student actually ends up
becoming the second best student in the
class and we're seeing this over and
over and over again in every classroom
that we've worked with whether we're
talking about public schools private
schools rich neighborhoods poor
neighborhoods wherever it is many of the
kids that even in two months that you
thought were slow you thought were
remedial you let them fill in that gap
even though it's an algebra class you
let them make sure they know their
multiplication tables know that
multiplying decimals adding fractions
negative numbers they can become the the
best student in the class the you know
the other oh yeah
the the you know right now 20,000
classrooms are using us in some way
shape or form I want to make it clear
all of this is we're completely free
it's all not-for-profit all of these
dashboards that I'm showing you you
could start using it with your cousin's
you can volunteer and if your local Boys
and Girls Club or your local school and
you can be the coach and you would have
the same tools that the teachers in Los
Altos have but with that we like to
remind ourselves that's still the bulk
of our users even though we have 400,000
in classrooms the bulk of our users are
the other five and a half million are
just people out there with just trying
to tap into their potential and what
this next video at least shows us and
hopefully shows you as well is just how
much potential there is out in the world
if we just give people the tools to
actually tap into it name is Mark
Halberstadt growing up I was really
always a si student I think I was really
pretty much always pretty pitiful in
school I don't think I've ever gotten
higher than a B+ in any math class ever
particularly I pretty much thought that
the only thing I was good enough to do
in college was major in music and I went
off and I got a music degree in
saxophone but I sort of almost felt it
was more I was getting it because I was
terrible at everything else kinda worked
as a saxophone player for a few years
really why I wanted to do was do
electrical engineering and the last
thing that I remember completely not
getting was trig identities so I went to
YouTube and I did a search for trig
identities and the Khan Academy was the
first thing that popped up watched a
bunch of videos in the trig playlist to
kind of get caught up to speed I watched
all the videos in the calculus playlist
I watched all the videos in the physics
playlist watched a bunch of videos on
dividing decimals and even on a
subtraction by borrowing I watched a lot
of videos on on arithmetic that was in
2007 I did that until the fall of 2010
and in the fall 2010
I took a leap I decided to go go back to
school and went to Temple University
majored in electrical engineering gang a
second bachelor's and keep in mind I
don't think I've ever gotten above a B+
in math classes and I was really a
straight C student growing up and I just
finished this year first year back in
college I got a 4.0 GPA for the entire
year I got perfect scores on both of my
calc final exams and also on my
chemistry final exam
I ended calculus chemistry both calculus
classes couple end to end chemistry with
an average higher than a hundred percent
I there are some Khan Academy videos
that I probably listen to the same
concept over 20 or 30 times and there is
no to hurt in the world I could have
paid to have sat next to me and repeated
the same thing over 20 or 30 times
without at least them getting a little
bit judgmental or at least them thinking
like oh well this guy really is never
going to get this concept and he should
just give up where the understanding
really happened was watching those
videos and also working through the Khan
Academy software and everything the
impact for me in my life
I really see it growing exponentially
over the next 20 or 30 years so from the
bottom of my heart thank you and Mark is
now a junior and still has a 4.0 GPA so
he's doing quite well maybe you'll apply
for an internship with some of you guys
so keep a lookout so that the one thing
that might some of you all have might
have been thinking about I even saw that
map or some of y'all are from is you
know everything I've been focused on so
far has been the english-speaking world
the developed world but the implications
on the developing world could be even
larger where you have lack of resources
or even if you have the resources you
might not be able to find teachers where
the kids have all sorts of there are all
different types of skill levels and so
we started to have other groups take
what we're doing other not-for-profits
for the most part but even some
governments take our stuff and start to
deploy it all over the world and these
are pictures of Connick
being used in various parts of the world
and each of these are exciting stories
but the one for us that's kind of been
the most mind-blowing is the one up
there in the top right you know I used
to give talks like this about a year ago
and say you know one day this might be
used in Mongolia and about a little
after that I got an email from Mongolia
it was actually from Ziya that the girl
on the top right and she actually sent a
YouTube thank you not too different than
what you just saw from Mark Halberstadt
and I assume she must be a middle-class
girl she has access to YouTube and
whatever else but then I read the email
in more depth and it turned out that
there was a group from Silicon Valley
who in their vacation time a group of
engineers was going to Mongolia and
setting up a kind of a computer labs in
orphanages and what you see there that
top right those are girls in a Mongolian
orphanage using Khan Academy and Ziya
was one of the orphans and that by
itself was was cool enough but then zyre
herself was now 17 got so into it that
she's are not she's now this is a 17
year old orphan girl is now our prime
producer of content in the Mongolian
language she is essentially the teacher
for her country and so it's kind of one
of these surreal sci-fi type of things
and so what I want to show you now is
the direction we're going in in terms of
internationalization we have 4,000
videos in English we now have 7,000 and
I think 20 languages and our goal is to
frankly have 80,000 in 20 languages and
maybe more and maybe even have regional
specific content and so this next
montage shows you a little taste of what
those with those other videos look like
and they're already available on the
site at the bottom there's a little bit
of a drop and it ends with a little
video why is that like my TV icon
do you enjoy a porno hi
sigh he's - Island random as a cod killa
face moon to the moon to the moon as
otras causes importance make more I
watch that one eye i watch that when i
get lazy
so so I'd like to point out I mean you
know it started with me and my cousins
but III like to emphasize it's not just
to me anymore it's a team of folks where
we're approaching 40 people and I and I
like to emphasize I think we're at a
special time in history you know
literally a Gutenberg moment not even a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity I don't
ever think it's a once in a millennia
where you can have real reach and real
scale and what I point out is you know
our team over the last year average 24
employees we've been growing quite fast
but we've been able to reach 43 million
unique students over the past year and I
point out if it was actually drawn to
scale that second bar should be 20
kilometers high so you know big picture
the original tagline on that was just
the necessities but there was a you know
big picture education has traditionally
viewed as a very scarce thing a thing
that's expensive a thing that really
differentiates between the haves and
have-nots even when people did
philanthropy it was always what are the
rich half well that's expensive let's
create a cheap approximation of it and
let's try to give it to the poor because
they had nothing before so it's better
than nothing
but what's exciting now is I think we're
entering a reality where we don't have
to give the poor even a cheap
approximation we can give students like
Ziya and the other girls in our
orphanage the exact same thing that Bill
Gates's children have so we're going
into a world where education isn't a
scarce thing isn't this expensive thing
so 10 20 30 years in the future I firmly
believe that it will be viewed as a
human right and it will be viewed as
just one of these necessities like clean
drinking water shelter or electricity
and with that I just like to thank you
for for having us here thanks a bunch
Wow
Thanks